for the honor of Hogwarts you know I
never know if the gags they come up with
in these intros are clever or just
really dumb but I don't dwell on it
let's figure it out hey so on a video I
put up - not long ago in the break room
I said I thought it was done talking
about Shira and I'm kind of not this
might be the last one for a little while
but I thought that before so we'll see
this whole notion of sorting characters
into Hogwarts houses I've done before
I've done it with my partner Liz with
phase one Marvel characters I've done it
with certain Disney characters I've done
it with the doctor and I do plan to do
with some other things at some other
points but right now I just wanted to
talk about sheer us so I'm gonna sort
the characters into Hogwarts houses I
thought it was gonna let this idea go
but then Jesse gender put up her sorting
of the Star Trek next generation
characters in the Hogwarts house I'm
like no I want to do it so here we go
now I'm not gonna cover every single
character in this show there's actually
a lot and there's a lot of really great
more background characters that I easily
could have started as well but I'm not
trying to make a half-hour video out of
this so let's start with the main
character adora adore as a Gryffindor
Pope boy is she a Gryffindor through and
through she's very determined she's very
stubborn she is very into oh I'll just
do it myself or sometimes even
extrapolating out into nobody else can
do this but me not necessarily as a self
aggrandizing thing but like assuming all
of the responsibility that's a that's a
pretty dang Gryffindor thing and Katra
actress's Slytherin I really did debate
on this I had a couple of notions about
her and I did wonder if she's just a
really a Hufflepuff with a lot of
baggage and I'm not gonna completely
rule that out but at the end of the day
I think she is still slithering because
her main focus is on how does this help
me and she can obviously be very bitter
be very spiteful she's not necessarily
ambitious in the way a lot of slytherins
can be but she knows what she wants and
if she can't have it no one can and that
sort of possessiveness and that wave
looking the world that's that's that's a
pretty Slytherin approach to life so
let's round out the houses a little bit
more and let's bring in a ravenclaw bow
I did also think about possibly putting
bow into Hufflepuff but he really does
have that intellectual mind and that
intellectual approach to things
he's very friendship and bonding
connected which is a little bit more of
a Hufflepuff especially as hard as he
has that but end of the day he's into
his tracker Patti's into learning things
and knowledge he's into tech he is into
learning the rules and going about it
the right way and yeah I I think I think
being raised by a couple of academics
that that rubbed off on him in a way
that resulted in in a ravenclaw
now glimmer glimmers of Slytherin we
don't get a ton of heroic slytherins but
you look at what she is about and she
has a very flagrant disregard for the
rules
she is very into the results
she doesn't care as much about the
methods not quite so far as ends justify
the means but if something's gonna get
heard the end result she wants she's got
to be way more willing to go in a
direction the rest of them just aren't I
mean just look at the direction things
wrong with the heart of a theory of what
she was
willing to do because it would mean that
they would defeat the horde a noble goal
to be sure methodology that that went
rough on her and she is very end results
focused with a lot less attention paid
to how she's going to get there and
that's a pretty Slytherin approach
especially if you're gonna try and lead
that way
alright so I've teased a couple of ones
that I almost put in hufflepuff let's
talk about a straight-up Hufflepuff my
girl Scorpia all of her focus its on
friends and it's on helping her friends
and it's on that connection so I'm
building those relationships protecting
those people and not really even
honestly being about damage she can deal
out damage even before she reconnects
with the rune stone she is a formidable
opponent but end of the day she is way
more interested in helping assisting
boosting and protecting the people she
cares about then she is about the
advancement of the Horde she cares about
that because the people around her care
about that not in the abstract she is so
driven by her friendships and her
connections and yeah that is that's
pretty helpful so let's bring in another
princess and let's talk in tractor
trapped is a Ravenclaw and trap to might
honestly be the most ravenclaw ravenclaw
who ever raven claude she is just all
about the information the data the
knowledge the learning she doesn't
people very well that's not her natural
inclination and that's not to I'm not
saying Ravenclaw's are bad at being with
people but I'm just saying her focus is
so harshly on knowledge that's the stuff
just until she's really screwed it up
and it's brought to her attention it
just doesn't ping her radar how to even
be dealing with that she's just so
straightforward and so focused and it's
all about data it is all about you know
the the next advancement it's all about
the knowledge and
yeah super ravenclaw I did do some of
the more supporting characters let's
let's sort of knock a couple of them out
quickly let's do a couple Natasa
spinner Ella Gryffindor Hufflepuff so
competitive so focused on winning has a
plan for how to completely take out
anybody else and about making people
feel good happy to lose to frost uh
because it'll make the kid feel good so
quick to point out well it doesn't count
because we lost on purpose Gryffindor
Hufflepuff we have mer Mistah mer mister
was hard to place she's one of those
people who's a little bit of a we need
to come up with another house because
she's not a harsh fit in any of these at
the end of the day though and I I
consulted with Liz on some of these that
I had trouble with and we came to the
conclusion where Mista is a ravenclaw
that's a little bit by default the way
we got there might get a little bit odd
but the first thing is she is into
stimulating her mind she loves a mystery
she loves engaging that was she's very
disaffected and distance and they're
like yeah whatever but she does still
get excited by a mystery by figuring
things out by having that kind of
approach to things and the ultimate
clincher was Liz and I have a mutual
friend who reminds us more than a little
bit of noir Mistah and she's a ravenclaw
so that was kind of a clincher on that
let's jump over to villains real quick
let's talk about shadow Weaver
if entrapped is the most ravenclaw
ravenclaw who ever Raven clutch that
early ever might just be the most
slithering slither and whoever slithered
who boy so to the same extent that
entrapped ax is focused on knowledge and
learning shadow Weaver is all about
power magic power she doesn't care so
much about political or Sun but she
wants power she wants she has worked
hard for what she has she will not let
it go she
once more she always wants more and her
loyalty is to accumulating power not to
whoever she's actually serving that's
why she doesn't really have a lot of
compunctions about abandoning Hordak or
Katra for that matter and it's why even
right up until the very end she still
had one eye on how will we focus this
power how we'll make use of this power
and yeah she had her one moment at the
end there but yeah she's really
Slytherin let's get back to the good
guys and how about frost frost is a
Gryffindor and I think it was her
competitive nature that was ultimately
will put her over the edge on that she
was a little bit hard to place but I
think at the end of the day just how
eager she is to rush in there dash in
and just take on everything come on come
at me of my dad that's a acid Gryffindor
attitude right there and it's
interesting because you know her first
appearance she seems much more reserved
and then once she loosens up and doesn't
feel like she has to be all stoic
because she's in charge
oh boy that kid cuts loose and in a very
Gryffindor way let's get one more
Gryffindor hero out there Seahawk Wow
yeah and very Gryffindor top to bottom
between his love of adventure his
boisterousness his theatricality his um
ego again not to say that no other house
had an ego I'm a Slytherin I have a
massive ego but the fact that his ego is
very tied to his sense of being an
adventurer and of leading this amazing
heroic life that's that's a Gryffindor
kind of ego we don't have too many left
let's get a couple of more villains in
there Hordak I also had trouble placing
I went back and forth with him because
he's got elements of a lot of different
houses going on this really not much in
the way a huff alone on with him but he
obviously has that ambition that you
would have for a Slytherin but that does
seem to be more interested in reclaiming
his place at prime side rather than
accumulating power for its own sake or
for himself
which makes him kinda a bit of a true
believer in that sort of level of faith
determination unwavering that's a bit
more Gryffindor end of the day though
ultimately for all the shifts that he
goes through I gotta put him in
Slytherin ultimately because even though
he may not be focused initially at least
on accumulating power for himself he
still respects power over anything else
that's why he wants to get back in
Prime's good graces prime is the most
powerful he wants back in on that and
that adoration of power even if the ways
in which he is trying to accumulate it
are benefiting are ultimately gonna
benefit someone else more than benefit
him doesn't make him any less of a
Slytherin as for horde prime he was
tough I went back and forth between two
possibilities and the linchpin on which
it was gonna be was whether or not
I thought he bought into his own schtick
and what I mean by that is he's got his
entire thing of come and bask in Prime's
light I will bring peace and all of that
so the question for me that I had to
come down on the side on was does he
actually buy that or is though is that
the schtick he says to for appearances
or to engender that sense of that
cultish sense of be of his clones or you
know is is that a persona or does he
actually believe that because if he
doesn't believe it then it's all
inactive it's just so we can maintain
power that
make him more Slytherin but if it does
that's a bit more Gryffindor that's a
bit more just seeing out the way the
world should be and just doing
everything to make it that way and I do
think he believes it because at this
point given the amount of power he has
and his reach
he doesn't have to keep up appearances
anymore he's in control of virtually
everything he doesn't have to put on an
act
for anybody so there's no reason to do
that anymore if that is an act
not to mention at the end when he's
talking about basically burning the
universe his whole thing about we will
all be cleansed with fire and he was
willing to go down that's not something
someone who was just putting on an act
does that's someone who is drunk their
own kool-aid does and for that reason I
am saying that he was a Gryffindor he
had his ideals for peace and perfection
in the universe that happened to
basically be him and he was just gonna
bring it to everyone that level of
determination that certainty that degree
of faith particularly faith in self yeah
I'm marking him as a Gryffindor we have
one more Swift win and he's a whole he
that he's that lovable guy he's so much
about the connection particularly with
Maduro with shira but beyond that you
know he never lose sights of wanting to
free his fellow horses free hay for all
he loves fun and hanging out and singing
and you know being with with bow and
seahawk and having friends and just he
can be a crusader he can get behind a
cause and all the rest of that but the
end of the day he just wants to have fun
and I find that very helpful there you
go the characters of
and the princesses of power sorted in
the Hogwarts houses what do you think
about my determinations and my rationale
for who I put where did it make sense to
you am I completely off my rocker
whatever your thoughts are drop
something on down in the comments let's
talk about it usual stuff you know what
it is like subscribe share this around
that's a big help comments are also
greatly appreciated all of these things
assist me and the algorithm and keep me
from getting completely buried which has
happened before so that is all
incredibly appreciated of course I have
a pastry on who doesn't these days link
in the description but don't worry you
don't have to do any of it end of the
day you're the council I only run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]